earlier tonight in Greenwich Village was
the world's famous New York Halloween
parade
now the parade always has amazing
incredible costumes people go all out
but I am sorry to say there were a few
costumes this year that the crowd didn't
really love and I thought it might be
fun to invite some of the least popular
costumes from the Halloween parade to
the Apollo Theater tonight give them a
shot lift their spirits share them with
you which we do it we get one more shot
first up ladies and gentlemen we have a
beloved New York treat it's the giant
pretzel on the ground getting attacked
by pigeons
[Music]
[Applause]
our next costume could come from any
drugstore on any corner in Manhattan
it's the mummy wrapped in one long Duane
Reade receipt
[Music]
this next costume is the vein of every
commuter it's the Port Authority vending
machine that's out of everything but
tums antacids
you'll find our next costume on the New
York Times op-ed page and in your
fantasies say hello to sexy pole Clubman
[Applause]
there they are the least popular
costumes from the New York Halloween
parade
you
you